hello belief nation today we're going to
talk about seven signs that you're
working too much and you need a break so
before getting into this video let me
first say that one I don't know if
entrepreneurs are working hard enough
there's definitely a hustle culture as
definitely that you got to grind it out
and do everything that you need to to be
able to succeed and you know there's a
go go go go go go go and I don't want
this video to be an excuse for you not
to work hard because you need to work
hard as an entrepreneur but if you are
at the breaking point if you're
experienced one of these seven things
then it may be time to pull off the
throttle just a little bit to get your
life back in order some of them are
obvious especially the ones at the start
and I think that once you get later into
the video and number five six and seven
are a little bit unexpected so let me
know what you think
so number one is your health is
suffering right if your health is
suffering to the point where there's
something major going on in your life
then it's often the sign that you are
working too hard for me I'm gonna be
doing this before I was going through a
super stressful time in my business when
I was taking over trying today in salsa
and my stomach was hurting and I
couldn't sleep and I had to go see a
doctor and they gave me stress pills and
I'd never had stress pills I you know
obviously had some degree of stress as
an entrepreneur my whole life but I've
never had to take medication for it and
so that was a signal to me that
something had to change the way I manage
the businesses had to change so if your
health is deteriorating you know then
you can only go on for so long before
something breaks and that could be a
sign that you're working too hard
number two is that your spouse is lonely
and this is for those of you who
obviously married or in relationships
this one is touchy and you have to make
a judgment call for yourself how much
time you want to spend with your spouse
versus your work but entrepreneurs can
have one of the highest divorce rates
can be super hard to maintain
relationships because we are so busy
what we're doing and it often comes from
your spouse feeling like they're not
getting enough attention to not get in
enough time this is something I
constantly try to check with Nina to see
how she's doing and she lets me know
when she's lonely and when I may need to
adjust one thing I found super helpful
is to try to involve your spouse in the
business maybe not as a partner or doing
any of the work but even just explaining
what's going on why you're so stressed
why are you working hard as opposed to
you know I have my personal life and I
have my business life and there's no
blend I find that by explaining to Nina
what's happening in my business it it
doesn't make her feel so lonely it makes
her feel connected to what I'm doing
she's try to think of ideas to help me
get to the next step sometimes she can
be involved herself personally and so
I've found that to be super helpful
again it depends on your relationship
you know some people criticize Gary
Vaynerchuk for his all hustle all work
all the time 16 hours a day you know not
spend any time with his wife or his kids
a very limited amount of time and that's
the life that he chose and his wife is
happy with as well right like who are we
to judge how he spends his time and I'm
not here to judge you and say this is
how you should spend your time with your
spouse but if your spouse is
consistently feeling lonely and left out
then that's likely a sign that for this
relationship you're working too hard
the number three sign is you can't spend
time with your kids again this is for
those of you who are married who have
kids one of the things that people often
start a business to be a tool so that
they can free up their time eventually
and to provide them with an income
source that can maybe be passed on or
allowed them to spend more time with
their kids and family and off it ends up
being the opposite you spend more time
on your business than you do with your
family compared to when you have a job
before I don't see a business just as a
tool to get somewhere else I get great
satisfaction from my business I love the
work that I do and hopefully you do as
well with your company not just a means
to an end not just a way to make money
but something that I can put my passion
into and have I mean full impact on
other people I hate when that comes at
the expense though being able to spend
time with Hayden as an example it's a
summer now Hayden finishes his camp
earlier than when he did his school so I
pick him up from camp every Tuesday as
an example yesterday was Tuesday these
four knows according this videos and I
took him swimming and I spent Tuesday
afternoons with him and my dad came over
when we all went swimming together and I
spent the whole afternoon
swimming with Hayden and getting to know
him a little bit better and teaching him
how to swim and again this is a judgment
call that you need to make for yourself
again using Gary B as the example he's
talking about how he didn't know his
father until he was 14 years old
you know when he woke up in the morning
he said I already left to work and his
dad came back after you'd already gone
to sleep
didn't really know who his dad was and
who was 14 and that works for him
he says that he was perfectly parented
so he's not angry at his father for it
and again it's not something that I'm
telling you that this is the only way to
do it for me if I find that I'm
regretting not spending time then it
then it makes me feel like I'm doing too
much work I really enjoyed going on our
family vacations we went every year to
Orlando and I did spring training and
saw the my Blue Jay team and watch them
play and sign autographs and then we
went to Disney World and that was a
tradition for years and I tried to keep
up to a tradition for my family and my
son and you guys have seen some of the
videos but every year we go to Walt
Disney World
in a game of spring training and I
remember that being super helpful for me
and just memorable right so when I look
back on my life in my earlier years
those are the things that really mean
something to me and so I want to be able
to continue on with that tradition in my
family for my kids and not be so busy
working that I can't spend time with
them if I didn't spend those four hours
in the afternoon with Hayden swimming
being with him picking up from camp I
maybe could have made an actual video
maybe that video reaches a hundred
thousand people and that's the trade-off
I have to make right like instead of
impacting a hundred thousand people with
my video I'm impacting one my son but to
me he's way more important than you know
a hundred thousand people watch my video
and so you need to make that trade-off
for yourself but if you feel like you
cannot spend time with your kids and
they're growing up without you then that
may be a sign that you're working too
hard in the business
the number-4 sign is you have regrets
a lot of people who don't start a
business often have to regret that I
wish I did this I had this idea I wish I
believed in myself I wish I started you
know you guys did it right you started
your business and a lot of times I try
to make decisions through the lens of
not having regret where I look at myself
when I'm 1789 you're looking back to my
life and I want to have as few regrets
as possible and so if I'm scared of
something that can often be the lens
that I use to help me get my confidence
to go out and do it because I don't want
to regret it and that that helps me push
through any fear that I'm having at the
same time though if you're working
constantly with your business you don't
want it to to have other regrets you
don't want to you'll not be able to
spend more time with your parents before
they pass you want to make sure you can
go on that vacation and make sure you're
spending time with your wife and your
kids and the people around you and again
to whatever extent that those are
important to you I don't want you to
have regrets and there's always gonna be
that trade-off between work and
everything else that you're doing but if
you find that you're spending so much
time on your work that you can't spend
time doing the other things that you
want and you start to regret that then
that could be a sign that you're working
too hard
sign number five is you're not feeling
creative creativity is super important
and part of our business part of your
life as entrepreneurs we tend to be
visionaries we tend to want to you know
change the world in some way and we have
this thing in our head that we have to
get out and create creativity can
seriously be dampened when you are just
in execution mode working too hard as I
look at my business right now I'm going
crazy on the book we're about to get
ready for the pre-launch or doing the
videos I took over TBS there's a lot of
stuff happening a lot of moving parts
and I want to redo my website one of the
things that is on my list but I haven't
given myself the time to sit down and be
creative because to be creative you need
to free up your time
you can't go okay for this half an hour
I'm gonna be creative come with
something amazing right the creativity
comes in the downtime the creativity
comes in the shower and the walks and
the vacation sometime and so if you Jam
your schedule full of stuff then it
prevents you from being creative and if
you are a creative person and you crave
that and you need that and it's it's
also the highest value that you bring to
your business if that's suffering
because you're working too much on
execution then it prevents you from
doing the next great thing so often to
work smarter you need to work less to
allow that creativity to shine
the number six sign is you're not
hitting your goals tied in to the last
point about working smarter not harder
sometimes you can set a course and stay
on this one path and refuse the divi and
just be working working working working
working but you're not getting your
goals and often there's another way to
do it and it usually is most businesses
the thing that makes them a ton of money
the thing that they exit on the thing
that they become super successful on was
not the thing that they started with
they had to change you had to deviate
they had the pivot pivot is the new word
that everybody's you know calling it but
you had to change multiple times before
you hit that path and if you're just so
focused on doing one path and don't
allow yourself the time to go off and do
other things and explore then you're not
gonna be successful I look at my example
with my first software company you know
I was working hard it wasn't for lack of
work or like I was pointing every ounce
of energy I had into this company and I
wasn't seeing results and I was failing
over and over and over and over again
and it was so devaluating to me he's not
even a word devaluating it was still
devaluing to me personally because you
know I wanted to feel like I was doing
something important with my time and in
general when you put work in you see
results and here I wasn't seeing results
and it got to the point where I broke
where I said I quit and because I hit
that bottom it forced me to think of
another way to stay and it forced me to
look at my land successive forced me to
do things that I wasn't doing before but
I only made those changes because they
hit my bottom and it forced that break
and so if you're not hitting your goals
and you're just working working working
working working and you're still not
getting further along in the path and
you just feel like you're on a treadmill
then you might be working too hard I
need to take a break to sit back and
figure out where you should be going
what you're doing wrong and how to take
your company in the right direction
and the last sign number seven is you
wonder if you're in the wrong business a
lot of people start a business just
trying to make money a lot of people
start a business for the right intention
they think they love something but once
they get into it they don't love it
anymore they lose that passion and
what's super important to the
entrepreneurs who become massively
successful is they love the process they
love the work they're not just trying to
chase a result they're not just trying
to make a million dollar so they can
retire like I'm gonna do a bunch of crap
that I hate and work 18 hours a day so
that I can make money and then retire or
make money and then go traveling or do
something else because I hate this work
that I'm doing but I'm gonna suffer
through it for the next little bit to
make my money right that sucks
that's not the path the key for the
mostly types of people they enjoy the
work they love the process the money
comes at everything else the goals they
come but it's not the main reason they
don't do it just to make the money they
don't do it just to going that vacation
they do it to do it they do it because
they have passion for I make these
videos because I love doing I look
forward to filming dein recording these
for you guys and if I didn't then I
would stop and want something else and
you see all the wannabe YouTube stars
who are just putting out content trying
to get famous trying to get rich but
they don't enjoy the process they don't
enjoy making the videos and they flame
out super quickly and so if you are
wondering am I in the right business it
may be a sign that you're working too
hard not getting results and you don't
enjoy the work and it's time to break
and find something else now everybody
has doubts at some point not every day
is rosy and beautiful and sunshine and
you know everything is amazing you're
gonna have a lot of days where you doubt
yourself but if that's consistent if
you're waking up every day and you're
gotta go in and do this again I'm so
frustrated I have to go work on that
project or I got to do with this client
we're gonna I'm pissed at Ivy deal with
this supplier whatever it is if you're
complaining consistently then it might
be a sign that you're working too hard
and you're
the wrong industry so those are seven
signs for me that I use to figure out if
I'm working too hard and if I need a
break I'm really curious to figure out
what you thought of it which of the
seven points you resonated most with if
you would add something else to the list
let me know leave in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon